hello there folks welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
kind of book entertainment I'm your host
Walter penny is yak yeah I'm gonna stop
talking okay so uh today guys we're
talking about season one of the Netflix
show Luke Cage everybody should get
excited for that
yeah before we get into it as always
like the Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome comic show new videos
every single Thursday ok so the panel
today two of my good friends who should
we go with first hmm I like the jacket
so we'll go to Anna first I had a wait
Thank You Squirrel Girl is the nanny for
Jessica Jones and luke cage's daughter
Danielle spoiler don't know sorry about
that they get together never mind
neither show I know
ok cool and mr. Brian Florida how's it
going so Luke Cage sure get hype man
Luke Cage
by the way Luke Cage if it's just Lu
cage it would be the same pronunciation
as ok same thing is the answer Mike
Colter
okay so we're gonna go into no spoilers
first just their overall obtain of the
show just we're gonna keep it short here
but what you guys like what you didn't
like
no spoilers port or what did you think
of the show what's your overall opinion
of it pretty good I'd say it's pretty
good you should just stop it I liked it
I thought was pretty good some of the
middle episodes were a little more story
driven not quite as much action which is
usually pretty good but I think they
were a little slow okay in that story
telling but overall I liked it I thought
was pretty good okay okay I loved it I
liked really good music music I mean all
the titles are like song titles like all
the wu-tang references and like actors
even they're in it maybe so I thought it
was really really really well done
overall at least
I liked the pilot a lot less than the
rest when I watched the first I I was
kind of nervous for how the rest of the
series was gonna go but right as soon as
I got to episode 2 and kept going it
fell into place the pacing was off or
something it was everything felt very
calculated I was I'm glad that that was
not the case right I agree with you with
episode 2 is we're really kicked in that
might be my favorite episode think about
the season finale was a little whack
right yeah yeah that was a good one
I just episode 13 kind of fell off for
me for some reason like it was still it
was still good but it was like all the
following action like the climax was
like the first couple minutes 15 minutes
yeah and then everything else was just
like just a really long falling action
which is a weird choice to me but but
yeah I really like the show as well
those spoilers it was yeah it was a
really entertaining it's still in the
top quality you know type in Netflix
stuff it not as good as daredevil just
like a Jones III don't know it's it's
close there I think just jessica jones
definitely the best probably going and
cursor maybe the best film MCU so far
besides Loki I don't know that's a
bigger discussion but yeah in terms of
the Netflix shows I think that killgrave
was amazing so I mean it's hard to top
that too so it's a no Luke Cage might be
safe I don't know might be third but
it's not bad it's still a really good
entertaining show I wish some Mike was
like Mike Colter is really good as Luke
Cage as well really I like to character
a little bit more I think he just a
little bit more consistent
I thought the opposite actually liked
him better in Luke Cage because we got
to see his character way more rounded
out I did like the past all that stuff
but like I feel like he was just he was
a tighter character and Jessica don't
for which he had to be because you know
he was yeah I just think he was a little
bit more of a tighter character sure but
like you know they let him go free
obviously since it's a show so
but they didn't detract from him you
know I mean I thought it was he still
did a good performance engage especially
like the the final like big action scene
here's all this talking this dialogue
and that was pretty good and then in the
when you give me a statement in the
police precinct oh yeah get a really
really good monologue there I thought
that was really good yeah yeah it's just
overall we all liked the show you know
in terms of no spoilers I mean we're
into it I don't know where you guys
think you're comparing it to daredevil
Jessica Jones I gave my opinion with
Jessica Jones I think it's right
somewhere to it it's a very different
like feel to it usually it's very music
very culture based very personal base
right right away like right in Episode
one you get that like even the title
sequences like Harlem this we're set in
Harlem this is where we're going with
this it's got like an entire vibe to it
with the musical numbers and the staging
I was like the songs and stuff and
there's like the lighting of it is
really Empire to with like the red
lights or like pulp fiction II to or
there's like a scene later where someone
opens up a chest and there's like a red
light that comes out I thought yeah it
was for me it was on turn on par with
Jessica Jones just a tiny bit under but
one thing that it did better than
Jessica Jones on par with daredevil was
using Harlem as a almost character or
you know just oh yeah anja belen in the
series overall yeah and daredevil I
think does that really well with Hell's
Kitchen
yeah and so you know jessica jones
doesn't really have that you know she's
not tied to a play specifically right so
but with Luke Cage being tied to Harlem
majorly clearly like I feel like it was
a almost its own character I know what
you mean seriously that was really good
yeah oh you realized right I agree yeah
look the opening sequence showing like
the reflection of Mike Harlem on his
back like reject and I was back and he's
like punching the wall that's another
really good opening secret
yeah their opening sequences are yeah
they're always really good guys okay
that was my second-favorite opening you
know first is obviously daredevil yeah
and then Luke Cage and then just get
Jessica Jones's yeah yeah they're still
all the well it's very similar this is
your spoiler warning so if you haven't
seen all Luke aid yet thanks for
watching come come back when you they're
good they're good that's where overall
opinion we like the show
so spoiler Dianna what did you like most
about the show you could go into
spoilers
I liked the casting was really well done
and the music was really done I touched
on that little bit earlier it's that
they chose some really really great
songs even just like son of a preacher
man yeah
but the casting was really really well
done I loved seeing rosario back but
then she stayed and she the usual and
this is really expanding on her
character from the previous series yeah
maybe they had her a little bit but they
never really expanded on her character
only see it fully fleshed out Clare
Clare and really loved her character she
was like the best part of the series as
far as actors go yeah there was a
character like arc was amazing I liked
the little like references they had to
like old Luke Cage stuff like the girls
ran around like oh my gosh it's just him
running around reference is really good
they even have like the swear jar which
set up the whole sweet Christmas thing
so that you know he wasn't cursing he
was saying yeah and then always man are
you trying to turn the take over Snape
here like we are gonna steal that
reference cuz he said always a lot and
then Clara started saying at the end to
yeah I was right but I was like oh
not for hire but I really liked Luke 8
he's great too
pops was awesome he was he was gonna be
the best part of that show it was gonna
be and then they killed him way too soon
yeah I mean too early I understand it's
kind of the catalyst for everything but
you could have kept him in the show
somehow with flashbacks or or keep you
put in the hospital or something I
warned him in the eyes
yeah but it was too much warning I think
the show could have massively been
improved by keeping him on absolutely
and could have built up our feelings for
the character more because I was pissed
when he died but I wasn't like
heartbroken like hell there's a lot of
we have like really interesting like
bulletproof black man motifs that we get
to see throughout this which is really
cool I think is a really good actor it's
hard to play yourself yeah no he's
really good and he's like oh shit he's
like you man like that was awesome
really cool extended cameo or maybe was
12 I don't remember but he was he was in
there was just really cool yeah I know
he's like a huge nerd like he's a big
fan of like screen junkies and stuff
he's really cool yeah I was kind of like
I don't know I think we'll get into and
then he takes off the shades to like
make a point I was like are we gonna go
super-powered I we are we gonna see like
he takes off the shades you like he's
like makes you do stuff or whatever I
was like he's waited to get off kind of
looked at I was like oh shit happen no
he's not much of a badass
I do like when he found the sunglasses
in the dudes pocket after he killed them
positives I guess do you any more
positive stuff I really liked
cottonmouth I thought he was a really
good character I think he was well
casted and I really just liked his ark
although I thought he died too early he
was a freshman
so I think I like Twitter maybe because
I could not stand him but I think but
like in a way that they wanted you to
not stand out is really frustrating
today this is a bigger I'm just going to
this now so I think that the show
obviously because Luke Cage is based off
of like these black philippe
blaxploitation movies and like shaft and
all these like you know cinema heroes
and stuff like that and the music
obviously is indicative of those things
but the performances are so uneven
because we have we have the other
Netflix shows that are very grounded
very realistic almost in the
performances and that's in this show but
it's mixed with these hammy over-the-top
weird performances and I think they
should have picked one of the other they
should have went full-on with the crazy
over-the-top blaxploitation type
performances or just go full unrealistic
because when you mix those two it's
jarring and it doesn't make sense with
what you're trying to present like
Diamondback I hate it
no I thought you yeah and that uh that
the costume at the end I know it's
supposed to be like the in the booklet
man I was terrible modified it a little
bit but yeah and that's why with shades
to shades
she just talks like this and that's like
his whole shtick he was okay by the end
like I got used to it more but I just
but I actually really like them sure I
mean I he grew on me but I still think
that that was more of a negative so him
cottonmouth I wanted to like and I did
like and there was some good stuff with
the background with him and his cousin
and everything was really good it's more
of his some of his tics that just got to
me I think the only thing with his was
his laugh yeah that's why I didn't like
see I liked his laugh use they used it
properly in certain scenes but they use
it way too much they use it way too much
and all the time some of them were like
super weird like
does not fit with the scene but there
was a couple of laughs that totally fit
with the scene laughs up his menacing
quality for me like it was like man it's
pretty powerful but then they usually
one time like ten minutes later I'm like
you asked every day if somewhere insults
him if someone thinks he makes a joke
every time every single they did what
max is doing that for seven episodes and
it was too fucking much
I feel back on the I agree I think
properly maybe once or twice but but
that's that's what I'm talking about
with the over-the-top stuff there's that
one
police captain whatever I can't remember
her name like the performance and that
matches up with the blaxploitation type
performances like the over-the-top kind
of acting like that that's one of the
things I'm talking about with the
inconsistencies there and it just was
kind of driving me crazy I mean I know
I'm harping on this but this wasn't like
a I mean this is like the the most
negative thing I could say about the
show I really like the show overall I do
like just these are the things that kind
of we were just gnawing at me the whole
time and yeah like I'm saying with
Diamond back so they kill cottonmouth
and then they bring him down back he's
supposed to be the big bad guy but he's
the most and like the reveal was because
there was like some sort of relationship
so I don't like I like there you know
but like like temperament wise know who
is basically just exact substitute for
cottonmouth right at the end of their
like fight sequence when they're like
talking and they're in the middle of
fighting still and some guys like you
guys are you talking about your mom yeah
it's not that we're talking about that
anyway that fight at the end that sort
of reminding me of meteor man I mean way
up here but yeah but yeah down some fire
and Domingos like time here but okay I
don't have many honestly I really liked
it but there were some of the effects
that just fell flat for me like there
was some of the punching that wasn't as
realistic where the practical effects
that they did worked like most of the
like medical induced injuries like those
were all done really well like for the
most part but then when he's like
punching through a wall or punching
through the floor it's like very
different than being realistic it's it's
like or okay the the exploding bullet
test that we're watching on the TV the
guy blowjob that you see the blood
splatter the screen oh yeah that was
super cheesy and that I was like
well I mean the effects they're just
some of them just took me back while
watching it because there'd be really
good ones and then all of a sudden I was
like oh okay where the blood like
splattered the screen and head exploded
and I was like oh yeah very weird
yeah any other negatives from you some
of the acting some of the secondary
characters were like pretty bad like the
chick with the ring that owns the pawn
shop when she was talking to Luke and
then mike colter head for the most part
he was good right but some of his times
like where he had to like yell in pain
or frustration or trying to like break
something it was just super force to me
like you really I feel like it's really
I think it's in for me it's nitpicking
with him but there's a couple times he
just really is just talking so
straightforward it's like he's reading a
thing you know but I think that's kind
of his personality I mean I watch some
interviews with him they're just kind of
how he talks so I can't really fault him
for that too much but sometimes it's a
little stilted with him but I mean
that's a major nitpick I mean he's not
he's in the performance-wise he was
great yeah I think it was one thing that
you actually robbed no when we were
watching it was the not treating of the
second bullet or the stomach wound when
he was at the doctor at the shoulder was
a more serious one that's been there for
longer when she said was getting
infected yeah
the first one yeah they couldn't get it
on this one put it in like a throwaway
line about how they took care of that
too but they didn't say anything they
didn't do anything with this one do you
see both the wounds we go we gotta go
here folks let's rate the season A
through F I'm right there it's far from
perfect I'll amend mine to a a be B -
actually because episode 1 was pretty
good episode 2 was strong I really liked
it episode 3 kind of went down a little
bit and then 4 5 6 and 7 up until the
very end of 7 where he gets shot those
episodes I was like bored ok I was bored
not even that but the story like ok it's
a story driven series there's gonna be
some action but a story driven series
and I'm good with stories film series I
mean it was just I guess we're gonna
have to go here folks so social media
for everybody I'll order you can find me
on Twitter and awesome underscore Walter
make sure to like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash also comic show new
videos every Thursday from anyone of us
we always tune in next week because our
vs. series is coming back it's gonna be
porter vs. dog walker yeah I get excited
we don't know who they're gonna be doing
it ok so until next week I'm all too
pretty yeah these guys are great ok just
cool and we'll see on the next page
Oh